a manhunt is underway near st. Louis for
a suspect in another deadly shooting
police say a man entered the Catholic
supply store of st. Louis yesterday the
incident began with at least one sexual
assault and ended when a woman was shot
and killed
Omar Villafranca is outside the store in
Baldwin Missouri that is a suburb of st.
Louis
Omar good morning good morning the
Catholic supply stores a family-run
business that really just sells church
supplies and this morning they have a
police presence and crime scene tape is
still up now the suspect is still on the
run as you mentioned but police are
saying this attack is random now
according to the st. Louis post-dispatch
a caller said a man entered the store
yesterday afternoon and ordered the
women inside to strip at gunpoint The
Dispatch reports he then sexually
assaulted several of them and shot one
of them now police confirm at least one
sexual assault occurred but they say
it's unclear how many other victims
there were a 53 year old woman who was
shot later died at the hospital now
police say they're looking for a white
male between 45 and 50 years old he's
described as having a heavy build around
five foot seven wearing a black jacket
blue jeans and was wearing a large belt
now police don't know if the suspect ran
away on foot or if he got away in a car
what makes this interesting this we're
right by one of the busiest roads here
in st. Louis County so that's been
making finding this suspect very
challenging beyond the manhunt is on
such a disturbing story Omar thank you